.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T TALK TO A
LOT OF ACTORS.
MOST OF THEM HATE US AND WOULD
NEVER COME ON.
EVEN THOSE THAT COME ON ARE NOT
THAT INTERESTED WHEN YOU TALK TO
THEM.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT TO SAY IF
THEY DON'T HAVE A SCRIPT.
KIRSTIE ALLEY IS NOT THAT PERSON
AT ALL.
WHEN SHE HAS NO SCRIPT IN FRONT
OF HER, SHE HAS A LOT TO SAY.
MORE THAN WE IMAGINED.
IT WAS AN AMAZING CONVERSATION.
WENT ON FOR AN HOUR ON TUCKER
CARLSON.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
>> FOUR YEARS AGO, I WAS ON A
SAD AND -- I SPOKE UP.
I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS A BIG DEAL.
I VOTE FOR TRUMP.
PRODUCERS SAID I AM, TOO.
IF ANYBODY HEARS ME SAY THAT, I
WILL NEVER WORK AGAIN.
I WAS LIKE WHAT?
IT WAS IGNORANCE.
>> Tucker: DID YOU TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY WHEN THEY SAID THAT?
>> THAT THEY WOULD BE FIRED?
I KNEW THEY WOULD BE.
>> Tucker: WOW.
>> WHEN THEY FIRST SAID IT, I
THOUGHT RIGHT.
WHO CARES?
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS, I'VE
SEEN WHO CARES?
PEOPLE THOUGHT YOU WERE SO
BRAVE.
I SAID I THOUGHT I'M STUPID.
IT IS A REAL SITUATION.
IT'S A REAL -- IT'S A REAL
BLACKBALLING SITUATION AND IT'S
SO STRANGE TO ME.
ARTISTS ARE FREE THINKERS FOR
THE MOST PART.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> THEY ALL THINK DIFFERENTLY.
MY WHOLE CAREER, WHEN I DID
CHEERS, EVERYBODY WAS DIFFERENT.
THEY HAD DIFFERENT POLITICAL
VIEWS, DIFFERENT -- THAT'S WHAT
MADE EVERYBODY INTERESTING.
SO THIS WHOLE THING IS JUST
PSYCHO TO ME.
I DON'T --
>> Tucker: SO IT WASN'T THAT
WAY.
PEOPLE WERE LIBERAL OR GAVE TO
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BUT THERE
WAS A FREEDOM OF THOUGHT AND
EXPRESSION THAT ALLOWS ARTISTS
TO CREATE.
>> LIKE ON "CHEERS."
ONE OF THE CAST MEMBERS THAT WAS
GOING TO VOTE REPUBLICAN.
I REMEMBER US GOING LIKE YOU'RE
CRAZY.
OF COURSE HE IS.
BUT IT WAS LIKE WHO CARES?
>> Tucker: DID YOU TRY TO KICK
THEM OFF THE SHOW?
>> NO, WE DIDN'T TRY TO GET THEM
FIRED.
WE WEREN'T ANY OF THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS.
MOST OF MY CAREER, GUYS DOING
BLOW AND GUYS DOING REHAB AND
THEY'RE NOT KICKED OFF.
WOMEN TEND TO GET KICKED OFF
MORE IF THEY'RE THING DRUGS AND
WITH PROSTITUTES.
YOU KNOW, MEN GET 12 CHANCES.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING I CAN SAY
ABOUT SHOW BUSINESS.
WOMEN MAY GET ONE CHANCE AND MEN
GET 12 OR 15.
>> Tucker: IT'S AN INTERESTING
POINT.
I'LL TOLERANT OF CERTAIN
PEOPLE'S DEVIATION FROM THE
NORMS DRUG PROBLEMS OR SLEEPING
WITH THE WRONG PEOPLE.
>> NO, YOU CAN BE COOKING METH
AND SLEEPING WITH HOOKERS.
APPARENTLY IF YOU DIDN'T VOTE
FOR TRUMP.
SO IT'S -- I FEEL LIKE ANYMORE
THE TWILIGHT ZONE WITH THE WHOLE
CONCEPT OF IT.
BECAUSE I -- YOU KNOW, AN
EXAMPLE IS ON TWITTER.
I HAD MANY CELEBRITIES FOLLOW
ME.
NOW I THINK LIKE THREE FOLLOW
>> Tucker: THEY TOOK YOU OFF THE
LIST?
THEY UNFOLLOWED YOU?
>> YEAH.
I'M THE SAME PERSON.
I'M THE GIRL THAT VOTED FOR
OBAMA TWICE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> YOU LIKED ME WHEN I VOTED FOR
OBAMA AND NOW YOU'RE THIS?
MAY ME HAVE TO RETHINK WEIRDLY
MY WHOLE FRIENDSHIPS.
I JUST STARTED WATCHING CERTAIN
THINGS IN THE WORLD.
LIKE I WANTED -- SIMPLE THINGS.
I'M NOT A ROCKET SCIENTIST.
I WAS LIKE I WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE
JOBS.
I WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE, YOU
KNOW -- I LIKE GAS TO COST LESS
MONEY.
I LIKE PEOPLE TO HAVE GOOD
SCHOOLS AND JUST REALLY COMMON
SENSE KIND OF THINGS.
SO WHEN I WAS LISTENING TO TRUMP
SAY WHAT HE WAS GOING TO DO, I
THOUGHT WELL, YOU'RE SAYING
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT WHAT I
THINK WE SHOULD DO.
HE'S NOT LIKE MR. DRUG DRUGS,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
HE'S NOT MR. PHARMACEUTICAL.
AND I HAVE MY OWN VIEWS ON WHAT
IS GOING ON IN OUR COUNTRY.
HOW MANY ARTISTS WE'VE LOST TO
FENTANYL AND OTHER DRUGS AND
[BLEEP] SITTING IN FRONT OF OUR
FACES.
SO I FELT LIKE I LIKE TO GIVE
THIS GUY A CHANCE.
>> Tucker: SO HIS FIRMNESS ON
DRUGS, DRUGS KILL PEOPLE,
OBVIOUSLY HURTING THE COUNTRY.
HE SAID THAT OUT LOUD.
>> HE SAID THAT -- LIKE WHY IS
EVERYBODY DOING DRUGS NOW?
WHY IS EVERYBODY ON
PHARMACEUTICALS?
>> Tucker: SUCH A GREAT
QUESTION.
>> WHY ARE WE ALL SUDDENLY
MENTALLY ILL?
WE AREN'T.
IF WE -- IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T
AGREE THAT EVERYTHING -- HE MAY
SAY THIS OR HE MAY NOT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T WANT WORDS IN HIS MOUTH.
BUT IT'S NOT LIKE DEPRESSION
DOESN'T EXIST.
IT'S NOT LIKE POSTPARTUM DOESN'T
EXIST.
IT'S NOT LIKE ANXIETY DOESN'T
IT'S WHAT DO YOU DO ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> SO IN MY UNIVERSE, IT'S WHAT
DO YOU DO ABOUT IT.
MY -- I SAID SOMETHING ON
TWITTER OTHER DAY.
STOP DRUGGING EVERYBODY.
OH, ARE YOU A DOCTOR?
DO I HAVE TO BE -- I WANT TO
CUSS RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: GO AHEAD!
>> DO I HAVE TO BE A EFFING
DOCTOR TO NOT WANT TO TAKE A
MILLION PHARMACEUTICALS?
HOW ABOUT IF I'M DEPRESSED AND I
FIND OUT WHY?
DO I HAVE TO HAVE A DISEASE?
>> Tucker: FIND OUT WHY?
>> YEAH.
IF I'M ANXIOUS, WHY?
IT'S LIKE WHEN I DID COKE, I WAS
ANXIOUS ALL THE TIME.
DUH!
I WAS DRUGGING MYSELF TO DEATH.
>> Tucker: AS ARE MANY.
APPARENTLY FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP WATCHED THE ENTIRE HOUR.
WE THINK IT WORTH IT